you can join the david pakman show
subreddit davidpakman.com
slash reddit r-e-d-d-i-t
nearly uh what are we up to it must be
about 33-34
000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed there a couple of interesting
posts and discussions i spotted this
morning one is from user dl1943
who says does anyone know where i can
find explanations for the jfk junior
stuff i'm totally fascinated by
conspiracy theories and always have been
obviously i do not believe in q anon or
really any straight up conspiracies but
i'd like to hear this whole jfk junior
stuff laid out by the people who believe
it not regurgitated through media
articles does anyone know of any
publicly viewable sites where the q
people post about this stuff or discuss
it yeah so listen my understanding is
that a bunch of i guess q anon type
people
believe that jfk jr who was killed in a
plane crash in
1999 i think it was
is actually still alive
some of them believed that
he was going to be running alongside
trump at some point or was in 2020 in
some kind of secret way or yeah there's
a million different iterations of this
and then others believed that he was
going to reappear
um i guess near the grassy
knoll in dallas texas a couple of days
ago and they actually gathered there
uh that's sort of like my best
understanding of it and i don't know if
there's any other
specific
reason why it's jfk jr
um there was some confusion because a
lot of the very same people who believe
that and are part of q anon are also
anti-vaxx
and
a really funny thing seems to be in one
i don't remember if it was in the
comments on a rumble post or some
right-wing enclave i could tell from the
comments that there were people confused
between this
jfk junior conspiracy
and the fact that
bobby kennedy jr is anti-vaxx
and it was just like a whole confusion
it was almost like um
q-ception i would call it where even the
q people were confused about the
concatenated conspiracy theories okay
anyway so that's my best understanding
but you know you you might be able to
find something clearer from someone who
actually believes it
a user mgsf departed posted to the
subreddit
why younkins at the time it was probable
but now it's now it's now we know it's
victory why youncan's victory needs to
be taken seriously
and they write younkin had absolutely
nothing to run on nothing of actual
concrete substance just culture war
noises and a whole lot of old-fashioned
lies
he's still ahead by over a hundred
thousand votes he ran all of the best
worst hits from ending critical race
theory which doesn't exist in virginia
reinstating family values a meaningless
talking point attacking teachers
and using things like critical race
theory as a blanket excuse to cut
funding meant to raise wages for
teachers and the idiots ate it up
i'm sure you've already seen the bumpkin
getting interviewed who said i don't
care much for crt while on the other
side of his mouth adding he has no clue
what it is it doesn't matter it's a
non-issue and it's one idiots i guess
they mean cling to the reality is simple
with or without the bs culture war
noises these idiots were all going to
turn out in droves for yunkan regardless
they're pissed and more importantly
they're galvanized they've been bashed
over what's left of their brains
multiple times into thinking their
voices weren't heard and now they're
turning out in droves it's not yet known
if democrats just didn't turn out or if
the numbers were not in their favor but
this was a win for the gqp and if it
really is an indicator of what's to come
next year we're in trouble
if junkin does emerge victorious which
he did and in active policies he's
trying to or tries to enact them then
the left needs to shine a spotlight on
it and use that to light the necessary
fires under our asses because the gqp
has gone full stone age on us and if
people remain apathetic combined with
voter suppression we're going to see a
lot
this won't stay in virginia
uh this this is absolutely correct
there's just uh i have so little to add
other than i did add on to it in the
first two segments on today's show
um the answer is not always run further
to the left the answer is not always run
further to the to the middle it depends
on the race uh there's not a
one-size-fits-all approach but the
one-size-fits-all approach that the
right is implementing is the one we have
to fight and that is fear and anger over
things that are completely untrue
that are being exaggerated or misstated
or simply misunderstood by republican
voters and it's really really hard to
fight that i don't have the answer i
proposed a couple possibilities earlier
but i don't have the answer but i think
this assessment is spot on anybody's
saying anybody downplaying
the effect or the significance of
tuesday's elections for democrats for
2022 even 2024 you could have a big
wake-up call it's going to be very ugly
join the discussion at davidpakman.com
reddit
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft privacy is a totally free
service and you'll get five bucks to
spend when you go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video